Ready?
There are lots of different liquids in
your home.
Mostly, they look and behave in similar ways. But when it comes to their chemistry
they can be very different. You can
explore chemical differences between
liquids by dropping an egg into them and seeing what happens.
Do you think something different will happen to them in each of the jars, or do you the same thing will happen?
Maybe the same thing.
Elodie? Do you think anything different is going to happen in any of the jars?
Which one?
In the oil you think something different's going to happen?
Okay, cool.
Do you want to put it in the oil?
It's getting bigger!
Hang on...
What's on the outside? It's turning white! Bubbles!
Yeah, lots of bubbles on the edge of the egg.
It's nearly lunchtime, so we're going to
go away and leave these and see what happens with the eggs in the vinegar and all of the other liquids.
And we'll come back and check on them later.
The vinegar! It's floating.
Goodnight eggs! Goodnight water! Goodnight things!
Which ones have had something different happen to them?
These two.
And what were the eggs in here?
A bit yucky! It does look a bit yucky doesn't it?
What is it in, though? Juice and vinegar.
Investigating how different liquids affect an egg
is a fun way to introduce children to
the idea that different substances
have different chemical properties even
know they might be the same
in other ways. Who is going to be brave and take out this final egg?
Do you feel brave Elodie? No? Viola?
No?! What do you think is going to
happen? I'm gonna get out. I'm interested
to see what has happened to our eggs.
Look at all of those bubbles!
I really think you should feel that.
Squidgy!
The acid in the vinegar reacts with the egg shell
which is mostly formed of calcium carbonate.
This chemical reaction produces carbon dioxide gas,
which is what forms the small bubbles on the surface of the egg
as you put it into the vinegar.
Over time, this chemical reaction completely disintegrates the egg shell,
leaving behind the inside of the egg, which
is now rather squishy,
and a rather nasty smell.
How squidgy do you think it looks? Do you think it looks quidgy like a bouncy ball?
Not that squidgy.
So what do you think would happen when we drop it?
It'll bounce! Oh, shall we see if it bounces then?
Yes!
Okay, everyone ready? Let's go!
OH!
What happened? It cracked!
It totally cracked, didn't it!?
To find out mroe about this activity, download the worksheet from our website.
Don't forget to subscribe to the channel,
and send us your own photos and videos
your own eggsperiments.